(gentle music)
♪ Summer after high
school when we first met ♪
♪ We make out in your
Mustang to Radiohead ♪
♪ And on my 18th birthday
we got matching tattoos ♪
♪ Used to steal your parents'
liquor and climb to the roof ♪
♪ Talk about our future
like we had a clue ♪
♪ Never planned that one
day, I'd be losing you ♪
♪ In another life ♪
♪ I would make you stay ♪
♪ So I don't have to say ♪
♪ You were the one that got away ♪
♪ The one that got away ♪
♪ I should've told you
what you meant to me, oh ♪
♪ 'Cause now I pay the price ♪
♪ In another life, I would be your girl ♪
♪ We'd keep all our promises,
be us against the world ♪
♪ In another life, I would make you stay ♪
♪ So I don't have to say you
were the one that got away ♪
♪ The one that got away ♪
(audience clapping and cheering)